hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game this one is from round
six of this year's Super United Blitz
tournament play being played in exactly
of Croatia it is Magnus Carlson versus
yaniponishi the two uh Rivals uh uh face
off against each other again as they
have in the their World Chess
Championship Match uh this time of
course it is in Blitz and it's uh quite
an impressive game with the most
intriguing ending uh Magnus seems to be
unstoppable he's on a six game winning
streak so he uh won all of his games in
Blitz and if nipple uh doesn't beat him
uh well he will just continue grinding
wins and Depot is trailing by a full
point if you remember that we went into
the wood section by Fabi and Nepal
leading the tournament that Magnus was
trailing by a point and now Magnus is
leading by a full point so nepo needs to
win this game in order to catch up so
let's see what happened here uh Magnus
had the white pieces and he opened with
D4 we have Knight to F6 C4 E6 Knight to
F3 and D5 so a standard Queen's Gambit
decline but Magnus goes for G5 3 he opts
for his Catalan opening bishop t7 and
Bishop to G2 Castles by both players and
uh D captures and C4 so the absolute
Main Line Knight the C3 and now Knight
the C6 we have Pawn to E4 again all very
standard nothing new here Rook to B8 you
don't really want your rook and A8 with
the Catalan Bishop being as powerful as
it is Queen to E2 and now uh Pawn to B5
defending the C4 Pawn we have Rook to D1
nicely aligning The Rook with the queen
and the D file and Knight to B4 now of
course you are looking to plant your
knight on D3 and white will usually play
Knights the E5 or Knights the E1 to stop
this Magnus decides for a knight to D1
and now there is a game where Rook to E8
was played but here we have Bishop to B7
and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so Pawn to A3
kicking away the Knight Knight back to
C6 and now Knight captures on B5 with
Bishop to A6 and now Pawn to A4 of
course if you just trade everything
captures captures and adapters then the
wife Queen also will pick up the C4 Pawn
so you can do that Nepal defends at
night day 5 and now Bishop to F4 nicely
developing putting pressure on the C7
Pawn uh Bishop captures on B5 now a
captures and The Rook captures and now
we have Knight the C2 uh so the knight
uh comes to uh to an active Square later
on you can play Knight A3 if needed you
can go Knight B for even Knights the E3
which seems more likely you can play D5
put an icon D4 so many options for this
Knight and while it looks like you could
maybe capture on B2 and make some
something work uh not really Magus will
just capture the Knight on A5 and he's
gonna be up a piece so we have Queen to
B8 and now Pawn to D5 a very nice
Breakthrough by Magnus uh with a
temporary Pawn sacrifice captures on D5
and now Ponte E5 attacking the Knight
here Knights the E4 and now he even
gives up his strong Catalan Bishop but
you will see why Bishop captures spawn
captures and now Knight to D4 this is uh
the move that we've mentioned again this
is impossible as the Knight on A5 would
be hanging so Knights the B3 are trying
to pick off the knight from uh from this
strong D4 square and Magnus goes it does
not capture the rookie goes Knight to C6
even though Knight captures on B5 is
very nice point is that after 9 captures
on A1 you can just bring it back to D4
with the Knight and A1 still hanging and
after the Knight moves you will now play
Knight to F5 with all sorts of nasty
tricks here against the black king and
this is uh well in magnus's hand should
be winning but he decided to go for
Knights the C6 instead Queen to E8
getting the queen out of Harm's Way and
now Queen captures on C4 now he's also
attacking The Rook here so Rook B6
attacks the Knight and now Knight
captures an E7 with check we have Queen
captures and The Rook captures on A7 so
for the moment it's equal material but
how are you defending the C7 Pawn you
could play something like Rook the C8
and the engine says that even this
should be played as passive as it is but
nepo rarely goes for the passive idea he
plays Queen to E6 and Magnus happily
trades Queen captures with Rook captures
on E6 and now of course Rook captures on
C7 and now Magnus is up a pawn but it's
not just any pawn it's the past B Pawn
so Pawn h sex creating some breathing
room for the black king and pawn to H4
we have King to H7 and of course spawn
to H5 grabbing more space this requires
no explanation as now pretty much
everyone does it uh without even
thinking you just push that pawn grab
more space and good things will happen
uh so here uh Pawn to G5 was played H
characters on G6 uh Alpha son this comes
with check and now King captures on G6
uh Rook to D6 offering a trade and uh
interestingly uh creating a pass Point
here for white is actually the best then
you play Knight to D4 and you just uh
continue the game it's not gonna be easy
to advance uh that pawn all the way to
Victory also you're threatened in Knight
to check the mess of the pawn structure
to remove the bishop uh so it could very
well be played however we have pawned
the H5 by nepo and now Magnus plays Rook
captures on E6 F captures and now Bishop
back to E3 we have Rook to d8 and now
Rook the E7 putting pressure on the E6
Pawn here King to F5 and now Rook to H7
attacking the H5 Pawn uh Rook to D1 with
check with King to G2 and now King
captures an E5 with Rook captures an H5
and King back to F6 so Magnus up a pawn
and nipple with The Double E Pawn so
Magnus is better but I mean I don't have
to tell you guys Knights are tricky
bastards and in Nepal sense they are
well most tricky so Rook Dage six check
with King to have five magnets repeats
once Rook to H5 checking to F6 and now
Pawn to G4 limits the movement uh of the
of the black king uh we have knighted
the D4 and now with ideas of Knight to
F3 and Rook to G1 and Magnus gives one
check but then he decides to go back
with Rook to H1 King to E5 and Rook the
H5 checking to F6 and Rook to H1 opting
for uh for a rook trade uh but this
would be of course terrible because they
have to root captures on H1 uh there is
the in-between as fish and sug uh Bishop
captures and D4 with check and even
after E5 you can even give up the bishop
here capture skin captures in your three
points to one of course completely
winning so of course nipple cannot trade
Rook 35 was played and now Magnus
advances it pawn to B4 uh we have Knight
the C2 attacking the pawn and now Rook
to B1 on always put a rook behind the
pass pawn and good things will happen
Knight to A3 attacks the rook and now G5
with check with King to F5 and now Rook
to C1 Magnus spots a beauty uh Rook the
B3 now Nepal puts a rook behind magnus's
pass pawn and why would Magnus allow
such a thing well of course for Rook the
C5 with check and now if nipple uh goes
to a weird Square uh you know he's gonna
lose these pawns but that's exactly what
he should do you should play King to G6
allow rookie five and okay those pawns
will fall but at least you survive in
the game after Rook to C5 check nipple
defended with Pawn to E5 and now Magnus
is completely winning and of course you
guys see why but just in case you don't
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the win for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting The
Mating net and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
Rook the C6 cutting off the king from
entering the sixth Rank and now you see
what's happening here the bishop cuts
off the F4 and G5 squares the only
Square left for the black king is the G4
square and it's not easy to decide on
this you really want to capture on B4
but if you do this then King G3 and
there is no defense against Rook to F6
Checkmate so the only thing you could do
after Rook the C6 is play something like
King the G3 yourself uh sorry King to G
for yourself uh uh so you know a king to
G3 is now not possible but then G6 and
you cannot stop the past Pawn if you
play Rook captures on B4 hoping to play
Rook to B8 now comes Bishop to B6 no
Rook to B8 for you and now whatever you
play doesn't really matter King
somewhere G7 G8 becomes a queen that's
it so after Rook to C6 never played Rook
to B2 but it doesn't matter Magnus just
play King to G3 and he was in this
position on move 50 that yaniponishi
resigns the game as there is nothing
more to be done here whatever move you
play here even a move like Rook captures
and F2 ends with Rook to F6 Checkmate uh
and of course no point in continuing
this uh so very nicely done by by Magnus
uh he wins his sixth game in a row in
the blitz section and well I think he's
playing against alireza now so if he can
continue this for three more rounds and
make it a nine out of nine uh it's gonna
it will be impossible to stop him even
now it's gonna be incredibly a difficult
to catch up to him uh he defeated nepo
who was the only player being just one
point behind him now it's going to be
very very hard to stop Magnus from
winning the whole thing but you know
there's an entire more day of Blitz to
play uh we'll see what happens uh so
yeah that's the game really hope you
guys enjoyed this beautiful Checkmate by
Magnus against his uh uh former World
Chess Championship Challenger Yani
ponachi I would like to thank uh James
Eugene Cashman John Austin not
complaints Paul Miller and Brad Roth for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this beautiful event until
it finishes thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day